Joshua Lederberg was a budding young
bacteriologist who developed a new
method that could allow him to validate
the conclusions Laurie Adele Brooke with
a method that was much more familiar to
the rest of the biologists and therefore
could be accepted by them as you know an
approach they could understand and and
what he when he basically figured out
was that you could actually make prints
of bacteria and the simple concept is
that you spread bacteria onto a petri
dish and then they will grow up
generating progeny on those plates you
could transfer some of those prodigy
place another bacterium on top of the
velvet and transfer the bacterium from
the velvet onto the new Petri plate so
it's very much like a printing press
where you have a master block and you
put ink on it and then you take that
block and some of the ink gets
transferred to the first page and
something that gets transferred the
second page of the third page and that
technique is called replica plating so
you could take bacterium that were
spread on the plate lots of them and you
could now transfer some of their progeny
to plate which had for example t1 spread
on them in the spontaneous mutation
model prediction would be that if there
was a bacterium on the master that was
t1 resistant some of its progeny would
be transfer the plate in exactly the
same place on each of the plates so
again by the printing pounce analogy if
you have over here on the printing press
you have an e it's got some ink on it
and you put four different pieces of
paper onto the master the e will appear
at the exact same place on each of the
replicas because the e was pre-existing
in the master and so that is thus a very
simple concept if the spontaneous
mutations had occurred prior to ever
exposure to t1 there should be progeny
all together on a particular part of the
plate and I will transfer them to three
different plates the new colonies should
appear the new resistant cells should
appear at exactly the same place on all
the plates the letter Berg predicted a
very different outcome if the mutations
were being induced
in that experiment the transferring
cells from the mass or to the plate with
t1 some random cell somewhere on the
plate will change to t1 resistance on
that plate and give rise to a colony
those same cells when transferred to
another plate the resistance cell will
appear randomly someplace else on the
complain so the resistance College
should not be at the same place on the
different plates because it was not
predetermined by whether there was a
resistance cell in the existing master
you